good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Monday y'all hope
everybody had an amazing girly swirly
filled weekend and speaking of girly
swirlies it's the girliest swirly who
ever swirled hey Jax you think I'm the
girliest swirly who ever swirled who is
swirly or me or you Jackie it's not even
a question we know who the swirliest
girl on the planet is but we can't share
that story
no we can't but it always comes back to
that doesn't it and I think it's just
kind of that's sort of the lesson here
you know yeah which is family family I
don't know okay okay that's a really
good lesson to start off our weekend on
um even though it's on our weekend it's
not the weekend
we'll get there you guys we will get to
making a good show no no that's for damn
sure we will get to the weekend that's
like kind of the whole point of today
it's like to get to tomorrow I was
saying we will get to making this
podcast episode good
we will because we haven't made a lot of
sense yet
I couldn't agree less actually
everything we're saying is making
complete and total sense to me I'm happy
for you
and I think I think people will
understand where we're coming from no
because the thing and you know what this
weekend was kind of just like a like a
reminder for me like I met so many
toasters this weekend and if somebody
was listening to our conversation who
did not listen to the toast like we were
not speaking English The Toasters
understand what we're saying because
even though it might not be you know the
language it's our language yeah I agree
and maybe you and I are disjointed a
little bit because we were apart this
weekend and it's definitely possible
we're kind of like
vibing with other sisters and stuff kind
of like forsaking me and I just
I think that might be why we need to get
on the same page today so by forsaking
you do you mean you know calling you
every day and telling you every detail
yeah that's exactly what I mean that's
exactly what I mean and I'm pretty sure
I called you guys I was like stalking
you no I'm pretty sure like we literally
were like we have to call Jackie oh
that's so cute thanks yeah well tell us
about your weekend please we left on a
cliffhanger turdy went to Luke combs in
Boston which broke my heart yeah and
Jackie unbeknownst to her put one of her
you know witchcrafty hexes on my weekend
she was like I hope you have a terrible
time I hope you know Luke gets
laryngitis and while Luke did not get
laryngitis bless the heavens
um I would be lying if I said I didn't
believe in the power of Jackie's
witchcraft because
she sent us off on like a really kind of
toxic negative note and you know it kind
of worked on the way there Jackie took
us seven hours to get to Boston it was
we there was not one minute we were not
sitting in traffic like we didn't have
freedom means we didn't get to cruise
until like the last hour we got there so
late we literally ran to the hotel put
on clothes and rent like it was just so
chaotic
and we get there and it's raining
and at first it's just drizzling and
Luke is not letting that bother him he's
delivering the performance of a lifetime
and then you know crazy lightning
flashes across the stadium and Luke had
to go like he was told you know it's
very unsafe everything is made of metal
you gotta go so what you're saying is
rain was driving thunder lightning
precisely and then there was like a 30
minute break so we were like backstage
and everyone was just like waiting for
the the go from the fire marshal then he
said
you're good to go Luke started playing
again and it was torrential downpour
like the craziest rain I've ever seen in
my life and at first we were like you
know that on the side trying to be
covered and then we were like it we
just like went into the pit and got
soaking wet and it was amazing and then
Luke was like listen I'm being told I
can only do two more songs because of
the Thunder I mean excuse me the
lightning and he really he put his whole
in the last two songs he just went
for it we were living for it honestly it
was so fun what songs did he choose
that's a good uh the kind of love we
make and I think beer never broke my
heart
yeah he like totally switched up he's
like I'm gonna play two bangers because
I only got two left and it was really
amazing I think in the end he only
played maybe 15 out of like 22 songs so
we got like most of the concert
um and he really I feel did all that he
could he I don't think he was even
bothered by the rain everyone was living
for it it was so sick like
my blowout was destroyed which was
crippling for me I realized like halfway
I was soaking wet and I was like wait my
brother oh crap my hair literally
my hair was supposed to carry me through
the whole weekend and then I'm sitting
there looking like I just got out of the
shower like sopping wet like my clothes
were I had to throw away my jean shorts
like they were unsalvageable
it didn't seem like you liked them
anyway
I actually didn't every time he posted
your outfit you're like weird outfit but
here I am yeah like the shorts were a
size too big and like they made me look
bad and I just like hated them so I
actually ordered a new pair I needed to
get a new pair anyway because I needed a
different size
um so I won't be lamenting over the loss
of those denim shorts
but me and Margaret were like looking at
each other we're like this is amazing
but like
what kind of powers is our sister
capable of it really felt like it was
you know sent directly from you you were
trying to ruin our fun we did not let it
ruin our fun but we did like miss out on
like probably you know 25 of the show
because of the rain yeah no there was
definitely hindrances and obstacles and
I did feel bad about my initial hex
because Luke shouldn't have to get sick
and suffer just because like I can't be
at his concert so I feel like the rain
was a happy medium you know yeah but so
we called Jackie the next morning and we
asked her to undo the Witchcraft because
we drove all this way like we wanted a
beautiful night we wanted the full show
and we were like can you please just
like put aside your jealousy and undo
whatever curse you put on us and she did
she undid it and that night was
absolutely gorgeous not a cloud in the
sky perfect weather wasn't even that hot
it was Perfection it was now you can um
take your headphones out for this
because I'm about to like brag so much
it's fine because I just want to say
like when I woke up Saturday morning and
I FaceTime you guys and you guys told me
how your evening was so treacherous it
didn't make me happy okay they did it
that's why I lifted I was like no I
still want my sisters to have a good
time like this isn't bringing me joy so
I want to hear about the good times now
so we we got there for the whole show so
there's like really like a nice lineup
and it was we were all saying it was
giving us like a mini Stage Coach Vibe
because we started seeing performers at
five and Luke doesn't go on until nine
and he's amazing
um openers the first opener is a band
called flatland Cavalry which is like
probably the smallest I hadn't heard of
him Margo had and they were really good
and then Riley green and Lainey Wilson
who are both like major country stars it
was really giving like Festival Vibes so
by the time Luke went on we had like you
know danced and drank and it was like
really really fun and then I just there
are no words for Luke combs's
performance I've been trying like all
day yesterday to like decide what I'm
gonna say because it's it was so magical
and I don't know if it was like an
especially good show for Luke or he just
does that every night
it was this is what I'm gonna say and I
think people are gonna freak out it was
just as good as the IRS tour
I believe it
his vocals were on point the production
was amazing like his band was incredible
and he
the biggest
um compliment I can give him
is between songs cumulatively he
probably spoke for four minutes like
during the entire show I hate when
artists are like talking so much it's
like great please sing like he did not
mince words he's like this
next song was my number one hit like
thank you for the background and now we
can sing yeah he just he barely spoke
and it was just amazing there was like
this electricity and everyone oh my God
like if I like it was in terms of the
the volume of the crowd it was just as
loud as eras me and Margaret were laying
in bed that day we were like what do you
think is Luke's biggest song like what
would he end with
and we there were literally like eight
songs that I think are his biggest songs
like beer never broke my heart one too
many hurricane Crazy Beautiful One
Number away like what what's his biggest
song I don't even know
when it rains it pours I think oh when
it rains it pours
we were just like and and that was so
modify like because I did I did
um I think better together
what yeah no wait maybe not better
together but that was like top five it
was like right now okay but it's not in
chronological order but out of the top
five
and the streaming numbers it's beautiful
crazy okay and then when it rains it
pours but like fast car is up there in
top five right now
um but it hasn't been out round as long
so it's like not really fair to compare
by the way did you see that Barack
Obama's listening to Fast Car by Luke
Combs no where would I see that you know
he does he releases like his little
playlist yeah and it's like such a big
deal for artists who get on it and he
literally had Luke Holmes fast car on it
oh my God that's amazing I actually I
always see the list because he does a
book list too and sometimes like a
redheads book or two will end up on
there and it's pretty cool and it's
further proof Barack Obama understands
it's never too late and he joined the
redheads it's true and speaking of the
redheads I read the redheads book this
weekend and it's really good and a
really quick read but it's also a Danish
choice so it's very literary but easy to
read like even snitch Breeze through it
not to say anything like about snitch
well like snitch is dumb
that's what it sounded like so you're
saying Stitch is done
um no I'm not but you guys if you're a
redhead like you know snitch doesn't
have patience for books outside her
genre that's why I'm with snitch on that
one by the way
but it did sound like I said snitches
down
it didn't no it did
[Laughter]
um okay so back to the concert so like
there was just everyone knew every song
like it was so major and it was like you
know not to make everything about me but
like all of us like we have known Luke
like since his first song like we've
really been following and I just felt
like this enormous sense of like
happiness and pride for him like it was
so cool and he's just so
regular like he's not this Diva
extraordinaire actually me and Marco
were backstage
um we went both nights and so both
nights like the same staff were working
at Gillette so we kind of became like a
family you know we kind of knew everyone
I met this you know this guy Sean and we
were like best friends and he was
standing right outside the uh bar like
we were just like all it was kind of a
camp energy we were literally and we
said bye to everyone like Shauna our
girl like it really felt like Camp
um and I was just asking them so many
questions because I feel like it's such
an interesting job to like work
backstage July you probably see so much
and he was like one of the guys was like
I've never seen this many people
backstage like usually like it's so many
like divas or big bands coming there's
like four people backstage you know only
like but Luke invited like everyone from
his record label and friends and family
of the band like it was really like he's
so I just love him like I was
just obsessed with him watching the show
it was the best show ever like I cannot
recommend and you know he's always doing
the most to like make sure every
possible seat is sold in the stadium for
like a dollar like he's not here to make
you know billions of dollars he makes a
lot of money and he's happy with with
that and he just sells I think like a
couple hundred tickets the day of the
show for I think twelve dollars so all
in it's 25
um it was amazing like I cannot
recommend even if you know a few songs
like you will know the Vibes are
Immaculate like and it was so toasty I
wasn't I don't know if I was expecting
it to be that toasty I hadn't thought of
it me neither it was toaster Central wow
how fun it was just amazing I'm sorry I
don't want to like keep look like it was
just incredible it's like one of the
best nights of my life no it was fun to
watch your stories the next day I
certainly went to his website to see if
like he had any tour stops like next
year in your bedroom I'm like the best I
could hope for is that one of his shows
his U.S shows in the next few weeks gets
canceled and gets has to be postponed
till next summer and wherever whatever
City it's in I will go he's doing his
International tour like through the fall
and then there's like one show next
summer
I forget what it is but I need to plan
for this pregnancy around Luke's tour
like this can't keep happening
no and he did the cutest thing oh my god
there was um right after he's saying
fast car the band was still playing like
the song fast car and he brought out
this kid Cooper I still would just he
had just beat cancer and I think his
wish was to sing on stage with Luke
Combs so Luke brought him out they had
like this tiny little mic stand because
he was like three feet tall it was so
cute and he gave us all the backstory
and he was like
Cooper's gonna sing with us please like
you know sing as loud as you can this
Stadium went wild the kid was so cute
Luke was just beaming smiling staring at
this kid he was adorable and everyone
was like
so I was like hysterically
crying it was so cute so it really had
it all it had you know Peaks pits like
it was just it was it was incredible it
was one of the best concerts I've ever
been to for real and I saw him at
Madison Square Garden twice but
something about being at a stadium
outside a beautiful summer night like
it's different it's elevated
yeah I wouldn't know but I'm sure it was
it was
okay well I I survived
yeah you did I survived the recap
yeah how was your weekend my weekend was
nice it was cute lots of fun activities
read a lot I saw Harry went to the water
park like major yeah he was a park boy
um fun activities coloring reading
yeah you know do you just no you're
ufoma for my weekend I have someone from
yours yeah a lot of art projects
so creative that boy yeah but it was it
was a fun sweet weekend Streisand was an
angel what more could you ask for
nothing yeah except maybe like a Luke
Combs concert in your living room yeah
well I had one on my Instagram stories
that's true I could not stop posting
like I I know people probably thought I
was like so annoying I'm Miranda
Lambert's worst nightmare
um but I couldn't stop it was every song
I'm like oh this is like his biggest hit
like everyone needs to see this
yeah no I enjoyed it and like people
could swipe out because they could
because
free will it's a beautiful thing and
it's a very real thing don't take it for
granted I don't some people think we
don't have free will
oh yeah that like everything is
predetermined
I feel that like that that's possible
for sure the way I feel about it is we
have free will to make our own choices
but God knows what we're gonna choose
he didn't like decide what we're gonna
choose but he just like knows what it's
gonna be he literally invented us so
like he knows what that dumb is
gonna do you know right like he knows
what's coming but you get to decide what
you have to take
yeah it's just like this
that's an interesting philosophical you
know core quandary yeah what do you guys
think do we have free will sound off in
the comments
do we have free will sound off in the
comments
anyways we have some great stories today
that we shall get into good stories you
know things in which to talk about that
I do need to talk about I felt like I
was so out of the loop this weekend like
I don't even know what went down so
you're gonna have to tell me everything
you these will all look familiar to you
got it okay
so without further ado I guess it's time
to die thank you the fast Side Story is
that you need to know
and the fast five stories that you need
to know are brought to you by eBay
authenticity guarantee so Jackie and I
love to invest whether it's purses
clothing shoes we're always making sure
to shop smart with eBay authenticity
guarantee eBay authenticators are there
verifying every detail of your purchase
so the eBay authenticity guarantee
protects buyers from fakes and it gives
them the assurance that they're getting
the real deal because what is worse than
spending money and time and energy just
scouring the internet doing research
looking for your next investment only to
find out later that you have been
scammed with ipe authenticity guarantee
you will never get faked over again
their service currently covers eligible
items across sneakers watches handbags
jewelry and streetwear we feel more
confident Jackie and I in ordering
online knowing that an eBay expert is
authenticating our items so so any
purchase that is backed by the
authenticity guarantee is sent over to
the authentication team who personally
inspect it they check it against the
listing and they authenticate it so in a
world full of fakes it's time to get
real with eBay authenticity guarantee
eBay giving Real Housewife energy in a
world full of fakes it's time to get
real with eBay authenticity guarantee so
this is such an important service that
eBay offers Because The Internet Is Wild
Wild West and I feel like everyone has a
story about a time where they spent so
much time money whatever it is looking
for something that they really wanted
and then ended up getting scammed it was
fake and eBay is doing absolutely
everything they can to eradicate that
problem so ensure your next purchase is
the real deal with eBay authenticity
guarantee everyone deserves real visit
ebay.com for terms today's episode is
also brought to you by Babel estas
distrautando Demi podcast thanks to
Babel I know what that means do you
so Babel is actually the second best way
to learn a language the best way to
learn language is through immersion you
know living where the language is spoken
natively using it every day but of
course that's not possible for everyone
so the second best way to learn a
language Babble because with Babel you
can start speaking a new language in
just three weeks this summer you can
start speaking a new language with Babel
why Babel because it works instead of
paying hundreds of dollars or as I like
to say dollars for a private tutor or
fooling yourself with language apps that
are little more than games Babel's quick
10-minute lessons are designed by over
150 language experts to help you start
speaking the new language in as little
as three weeks Babel is designed by real
people for real conversations all of
Babel's tips and tools for learning a
new language are approachable accessible
rooted in real life situations and
delivered with conversation Based
Teaching so obviously it's that time of
year where everyone's traveling when
you're traveling to a new country and
they speak a different language it is so
important like safety reasons and just
logistically if you have a grip on the
language so Babel's a great thing to do
in the weeks and months leading up to a
trip studies from Yale Michigan State
University and others continue to prove
that Babel is better for instance one
study found that using Babel for 15
hours is equivalent to a full semester
at college so here's a special limited
time deal for our listeners to get you
started right now get 55 off your Babel
subscription but only for our listeners
when you go to babel.com toast that's 55
off at babel.com toast and BaByliss
spelled
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash toast rules and
restrictions May apply at babel.com
toast thank you Claudia you're welcome
our first story Jamie Foxx is speaking
out for the first time since his
mysterious Health scare he says he went
to hell and back so he posted a video
speaking out for the first time since
being hospitalized following a
mysterious medical complication in April
in the video he fought back tears as he
divulged on the hellish hellish
experience he went through in an
emotional video he said quote I went
through something I thought I would
never ever go through he informed his
followers that he's not blind or
paralyzed I know a lot of people were
waiting to hear an update but to be
honest with you I didn't want you to see
me like that man I want you to see me
laughing having a good time partying
cracking a joke doing a movie or a
television show I didn't want you to see
me with tubes running out of me and
trying to figure out if I was going to
make it through he didn't disclose his
illness but he said he's finally on the
road to recovery he praised his sister
and his daughter for saving his life he
said to them to God to a lot of great
medical people I'm able to leave you
this video I cannot tell you how great
it feels to have your family kick in in
such a way and you all know they kept it
airtight they didn't let out nothing
they protected me and that's all what I
hope that everyone could have in moments
like these but I'm coming back and I'm
able to work
he said that um his eyes are working
just fine proving that he's not
paralyzed and he wants to say that he
has love he loves everybody and loves
all the love that he got and he's just
very emotional about the whole thing he
said he'll be crying on a dime for a
while when he's fans he's just very
thankful for everyone's love and support
and did he share what exactly happened
to him no
hmm so it remains a mystery because for
the last few months it's been like
uh you know it's been news that Jamie
Foxx was in the hospital but it was also
like not really confirmed and then his
daughter like did say that he fell ill
but still like all very shrouded in
mystery
um and also his health status like if he
was on right to recovery what was going
on he's obviously doing so much better
that he's able to put out a video but
still it's very mysterious what happened
yeah I mean he looked good in the video
I was um
like happy to see him looking
somewhat usual in it like what I imagine
Jamie Foxx look like
um so scary so sad glad he's doing well
I feel like so he is like when I think
of like one of the most like
well-connected celebrities in the sense
like he has so many celebrity and like
powerful friends and I feel like
everybody was like talking about it but
not saying what it was I'm still like
yeah everyone was talking about it but
like didn't have any information you
know especially like the
media and people maybe his friends know
what's going on but no one was sharing
no one is sharing well you know what on
his own time I hope he's okay I'm glad
he's like doing better how scary like to
just one day be fine and then one day
like you could be paralyzed or blind
yeah and for months to be in the
hospital right that's so sad well he
probably has access to like you know the
best of the best and I hope that
whatever it is they can figure it out
yeah I hope so too so but that was a
positive update because the story's just
kind of been like looming we haven't
even spoken about it much because we
have no information right right so it
was nice to just like see him on camera
doing well and letting everyone know
he's doing better
totally
our next story you guys finally there is
some there's some fire where there's
been smoke Tom Brady and Irina Shake
were spotted getting flirty and
touchy-feely after a sleepover at his
house so Tom Brady seems to have moved
on from his ex-wife Giselle the retired
NFL star was photographed looking very
flirty with another supermodel Irena
Shake over the weekend in photos
obtained by Page Six exclusively so he
picked a Irina from the hotel Bel Air
Friday afternoon and then drove them to
his La home and eyewitness told page six
they're told the duo didn't emerge until
9 30 a.m the following day when Tom
dropped off Irina back at the hotel uh
they then he picked her up again
Saturday afternoon in his black Rolls
Royce and returned to his house at one
point he was seeing effectual
affectionately caressing the Russian
stunner's face while stopped at a red
light and there is photo and video of
the caress have you seen the caress I
have seen the crests
um
I'm shocked because like I know we spoke
about these two like being spotted but
then we never heard anything again I'm
like oh it's just like people making a
big deal that they were at the same
party yeah they're in the same room and
they are both eligible and wouldn't that
be nice but that doesn't mean anything
yeah
um
this is just so layered for me I mean my
first thought was like if I'm Gisele um
I'm kind of like loving this because
Irina shake like really is like a carbon
copy of Giselle in the sense that like
they have such similar careers that kind
of look alike he clearly has a type
um so at least you know
it's not like he regrets everything
right right I don't know it's just it
would bring me peace honestly if I was
Giselle but I'm not clearly what I
thought I had really if if you and Ben
you know God forbid ever split up would
it bring you more peace if he was with
someone exactly like you or if he just
went in the total opposite direction
it's actually a good call right
yeah it's like well if you're gonna go
be with someone just like me like be
with me why not me but maybe if Gisele
was the one to end things like and Tom
was happy with his life then it's like I
just want the same as what I had right
right right I'm trying to replicate it
so I am it just depends on how things
ended who ended it
so another thought I had is like of
course Irina Shake is you know linked to
Bradley Cooper and what do we know about
Bradley Cooper He's the biggest Eagles
fan and I feel like there's like such
beef between like eagles and Boston fans
because it's like so you know New
England toxic Sports energy
Bradley Cooper's not okay but it has
nothing to do with like Irina shake or
him being you know like you know still
in love with her he's like this is
disgusting you know like he's
she is essentially you know dating the
father of her child's like biggest enemy
right sort of I mean he doesn't play for
the Patriots anymore and who knows maybe
they like are friends because they go to
like events together and stuff but this
is really a sleigh for Irene Shake I
feel like since she broke up with
Bradley Cooper like the way I've
perceived their breakup like hasn't she
didn't win you know yeah yeah like I
there were always these stories about
her like trying like groveling to get
back she's always like posting stuff to
make it seem like they're together when
they're clearly not together so true and
now she's coming out on top with this
even if it was just like one night this
is so cool for her yeah no it's a sleigh
it's a sleigh
it's a slay and a half that's very true
um let's not forget her brief romance
with um Kanye
right
but this is cooler yeah I feel like
she's been like trying to like have a
moment romantically ever since Bradley
Cooper and like she got it and we'd love
to see women in the workplace slang now
I hope that they continue to make each
other happy because you know I love love
but it's all we ever get is this one
caress it would be enough for me Diana
yeah it is really crazy that like two
people you know can't have a sleepover
without everyone knowing like they did
it's not like they were spotted out an
event and left together like somebody
saw him pick her up at like a private
hotel and then saw them leave their his
house like it's kind of like a crazy
invasion of privacy it is but it's one
of those things where under other
circumstances I would be like you know
they planned this they called the
paparazzi or at least like one of them
did no they wanted to be seen but
because he picked her up from a hotel
like maybe Paparazzi hang out around
that hotel really like figured out what
they were seeing and they staked them
out the whole weekend like it just where
was she staying Hotel the hotel at Bel
Air yeah okay I've been there it's like
super private it's like gated and like
the entrance isn't like an entrance on
the side of the road you like go up this
hill it's real and I'm sure Paparazzi do
stand like down at the bottom of the
hill like by the gate but like there's a
way you know yeah do you think she
called the paparazzi
so I I would love based on exactly what
I just said like she needed a whim
this looks so good for her
I could definitely see a world
in which she did you know
have her people call TMZ
paychecks excuse me this is a page six
exclusive I could see a world in which I
hate to think that way you know I know
me too it really bursts the entire
bubble like this fantasy we live in
where like we just are being able to
spot celebrities in the wild and they're
not like trying to show us what they're
doing but if it all is true like
literally everyone says all the
celebrities call Paparazzi on themselves
like then this whole thing is just one
big charade that we are like
engage again yeah because I don't know
the hotel Bel Air is like such a
frequent hot spot for celebrities for a
reason like it really is that private
what's more private than your own home
these are just two locations I don't
know I felt like
many celebrities
go to and from the Bel Air hotel from
their house and get away unscathed you
know
I don't know it's definitely making me
think yeah but again like if you're
Irina and I wonder if this was the first
time why do we have this like image of
Irena as being like thirsty like why
um I do I definitely see her as like
Thursday thirsty in relationships like
yes like because she posted all this
stuff with Bradley Cooper like
as if they were in a relationship on the
beach yeah like they were on vacation I
think like for their daughter and she
was like making it look like they were
together and they're just like not
together
and even when they were together it
didn't like seem great Wimbledon no and
like which we know but I was like the
Lady Gaga stuff she was just always like
on the outs it's so true and Bradley's
also the type of celebrity who doesn't
have social media he doesn't like a
publicist who like makes statements so
Irene is kind of free to put out
whatever narrative she wants because No
One's Gonna challenge her and we were
just seeing through that
by the way I completely forgot about the
Lady Gaga thing yeah you're right she's
been positioned as like
the kind of beta even though she's like
this alpha female she couldn't be more
stunning more successful yet she has
this like weird vibe to her image it
just image has definitely been marred by
that relationship yeah yeah
so I'm happy for her because this is
this is a w I think when you think about
the layers of what Tom Brady could mean
to her X-Man
I'm not saying he hates Tom Brady but he
definitely like you know
it's you know what it is it's kind of
the no I know what it is okay it's kind
of like the
the Joe Jonas Gigi Hadid Sophie Turner
thing it's like where do you go after
Bradley Cooper seriously where do you
where does Joe Jonas go after Gigi Hadid
and you know what
he slayed with Sophie Turner he went all
the way up we thought you know we he
couldn't possibly especially because you
know he was shorter than he was
definitely like punching up when he
dated Gigi yeah and then it's like oh
well that was fun for a minute and then
he could go back to you know dating and
Normie no he went to Sophie Turner and
like they literally are perfect for each
other and she's you know a global
international Superstar and she's
literally stunning
where do you go after Bradley Cooper
there's really only one place to go it's
down Irena Shake found a way to go up
and for that for them to absolutely
applaud her mess with Bradley like he
watches football every weekend even if
like he doesn't have anything Bradley
even if he doesn't have an issue with
Tom like maybe they're cool because you
know you meet Big Tom's the goat like
you can put aside your petty squabbles
it's true he has to like think about Tom
Brady all the time like he watches ESPN
he watches the sports and they're always
talking about him and it's just
she got inside his head I think and I'm
happy for her no
yes but I do wonder if like these photos
are going to ruin whatever relationship
has already started because like is Tom
not asking himself the same thing did
she call the paparazzi Jackie is Tom
feeling suspicious he should be I would
be yeah
I feel like also we don't get crazy
Paparazzi pictures of Tom Brady like
he's yes probably the biggest star in
the world but football's like sports are
a little different they don't really get
hounded by Paparazzi it's not Hollywood
yeah and mostly because athletes live in
like random towns because they live
where the you know stadium is Kansas
City so there's not like big Paparazzi
culture in you know New England
yeah but he has a house in LA
I guess his house is everywhere yeah
also like here at the bottom of this
article that said last month page six
exclusively reported that the model had
made a b line for Tom Brady at oh yes at
a wedding yes and that she scarcely let
him out of her sight throughout the
weekend long festivities she followed
him around all weekend The Insider said
she was throwing herself at him so like
these stories just don't help so is it
that irina's thirsty or is the media
after Irina it I'm sure like most things
it's a bit of both yeah
yeah because that like just that way of
framing it is so mean mean but why why
are they framing it that way like they
don't say that about everyone yeah
no that's interesting
[Laughter]
that's like honestly brutal like that's
humiliating
yeah
but look she Rose above it she Rose to
the occasion luckily Tom Brady doesn't
read Page Six
yeah but I'm sure he knows that these
photos and videos are out there now oh
yeah but I don't think he saw that quote
that she was making a beeline for him at
the wedding
because it's more of a turn off than
that
yeah
unless he was making beeline for her I
must say misread the whole thing
yeah like how would they even know that
what's going on in her head
right yeah
we have to give Irina Grace we have to
let's give Irina Grace yeah
deserves it she does but you know what
she's doing it she deserves it she
deserves it she's been through a lot we
all remember those photos at Wimbledon
yeah but she's doing okay today she had
a good weekend yeah wimbledon's always
making news
I know
this year it was Irena years no this
year it was Ariana in years past it's
been Irena in years past it's been Megan
and Kate mm-hmm
it's kind of this um
hotbed of celebrity scandal you know
it's like it's a it's an event it's like
the Met Gala like yeah what's who's
going who's sitting with who who's
talking to who right and it's kind of
like celebrity like you're observing
celebrities for like hours at a time in
one place not just like a red carpet
photo and then bounce like you have to
see them out in out in the elements you
know yeah interacting sitting
it's kind of gorgeous it's kind of like
anthropological yes if you will I'm
using anthropological gorgeous yeah
that's let's use that that's our word of
the day let's try and use it one more
time okay are you ready for our next
story no you're not no our next story is
brought to you by masterclass which I'm
excited to talk about because I listen
to a Master Class
um on our road trip it was such a
fabulous way of making the time pass so
with masterclass you can learn from the
best to become your best anytime
anywhere and at your own pace so annual
memberships start at ten dollars a month
and you get unlimited access to every
instructor thousands of online lessons
exclusive content insights and more so
masterclass has over 180 classes to pick
from they have everything from Kris
Jenner to Bob Iger and they add new
classes every month so they have Gordon
Ramsay Malcolm Gladwell Steve Martin oh
I gotta listen to The Steve Martin one
we listen to the Kris Jenner one in the
car Chris Boss Esther perel Mariah Carey
and many more
so you can find practical takeaways that
you can apply to your life and at work
if you run a business you can use
masterclass to help your team you're
basically gaining new skills in as
little as 10 minutes either on your
phone computer Tablet Smart TV and even
audio mode to listen on the go which is
what we did in the car you know
connected to carplay listen to Kris
Jenner it was fabulous so how much would
it cost to take one-on-one classes from
the world's best I mean literally
millions of dollars but with a master
class annual membership it would only
cost ten dollars a month you can get
unlimited access to every class and
right now as a toast listener you can
get 15 off when you go to
masterclass.com toast that's
masterclass.com toast for 15 off an
annual membership masterclass.com toast
also a great gift to give someone for
whatever
um you know Niche or interest that they
have it's a fabulous way to extend a
courtesy as a gift you know I loved
listening to Chris's like about building
a business how the girls like use social
media it was really topical like for
what we do and I just loved it yeah you
can really learn so much on it it's a
great if I've gifted it before and it's
really thoughtful and helpful yep
okay our next story we have an update on
Graham gate we have a couple updates
James Kennedy has renamed his and
Raquel's dog after the alleged biting
streak so James posted to Instagram this
weekend a picture of the dog formerly
known as Graham and he said hippie heart
he said we've decided to rename this
little beauty hippie this is a tribute
to my late Godfather George Michael's
dog's name the only dog I saw around the
house growing up although George and
hippie are in heaven now together I know
that they are watching over me now a
proud doggy Papa
so we'll talk about the name change but
also over the weekend Raquel's mom spoke
out about why she surrendered Graham um
after he bit her so Raquel's mom Laura
claims she surrendered Graham after the
canine bit her quote To The Bone she
told Entertainment Tonight Rachel put
Graham into Behavior classes after
breaking up with James because he had
bitten several people When Rachel went
into the mental health facility she
asked us to care for Graham as we have
many times before while caring for him
he bit me to the Bone causing severe
damage she said I saw two doctors for
the wound that suggested he be
euthanized which we absolutely declined
and sought out the best Rehabilitation
Center California doodle rescue that
gave him a trainer with over 40 years of
experience after discussing the matter
with Raquel Laura said she decided
putting Graham in the care of California
doodle rescue was the best option she
said we made the tough decision to drive
Graham on May 20th to California doodle
rescue so that he wasn't alone and
delivered him directly to the trainer's
home with a tearful goodbye
Raquel's mom went on to claim that
Graham bit both as a trainer and her
husband although the pair was able to
get him to a place where he could be
adopted so then he was placed with a new
owner and was returned within three days
after also biting her oh my God yep the
rescue then reached out to Lisa
Vanderpump for financial assistance to
hire a different trainer Lisa offered to
adopt Graham and he was picked up by
Vanderpump dog's rescue on July 13th
then Laura Raquel's mom said that
California doodle rescue was given the
impression that Banner to pump dogs
would either rehabilitate Graham and
place him in a good home or that he
could live on the Vanderpump uh property
for the remainder of his life she said
my daughter nor I ever dumped Graham and
want nothing but the best for him and
then eventually Graham was reunited via
Vanderpump dogs with
James who has now renamed him so that's
the whole story maybe there's still more
but it's much more than we had last week
no and you know what I'm glad that we
reserved judgment last week because
there's far too much detail in that
story for Raquel's mom to be lying and
Raquel's mom is not like thirsty like
she didn't have to speak out like no
Raquel I just believe a regular woman
I'm sure the thing and Raquel's not in
the facility anymore but maybe not in a
place to be like you know speaking to
the press or trying to say her name and
like this was like the things people
were saying about Raquel for
surrendering her dog and it was Graham
who we seemed like we know and we've
never known him to have behavioral
issues like it was so out of left field
like I'm actually very glad that her mom
spoke up and gave context to the story
because it seems like this has been an
ongoing saga not just like Raquel woke
up one day and was like I can't take
care of my dog yeah oh yeah yeah no and
the kind of crazy part is like after all
that Rehabilitation somebody adopted him
and returned him three days later right
it's very much like Lucy Lucy like you
try and do like you take all the right
steps but you do have this dog to bite
down to the bone yeah you know flexible
times yeah that's really crazy
um it seems like everybody tried to do
the right thing and now you know all as
well that ends well to end up with James
yes hopefully James can provide an
environment for him where he's not
biting people but what do you think
about James changing his name I'm not
here for it
um don't get me wrong I changed Theo's
name like four days after getting him
he was three months old I don't know how
old this dog is but I've known the dog
for a few years so the dog is at least a
few years old yeah they adopted Graham I
think in 2018. so he's at least five
that's very confusing for a dog
especially a dog that's having
behavioral issues like you use a dog's
name in Training so much and you know
dogs don't know a lot but they know
their names yeah and especially like
Graham knows James and Graham knows
James as Graham so like then for that
person who's always called him Graham to
then call him hippie I imagine it's
confusing but when people adopt dogs
from shelters that weren't their
ex-girlfriend's dog before you know yeah
yeah do they change their name or do
they come with the name that's a good
question I feel like
they come with the name I actually I
don't know I mean if you're adopting
like a senior dog you're not going to be
out here changing the dog's name yeah
I guess it depends how old the dog is
and I think you could do whatever you
want really maybe and maybe there are
some people who you know believe that
having a fresh start a new name might be
like a good thing for the dog I'm sure
there are schools of thought that would
say that and other people might say that
the familiarity of the name
what's in a name that's an amazing
question
yeah I mean I wouldn't have changed the
name but I also Imagine Ali's probably
like like Graham is like Raquel you know
what I mean like I get that yeah
Graham and then like you just hear her
voice every time you say the dog's name
yeah so I get it but I probably wouldn't
have done that it's confusing for a dog
especially a dog that's clearly been
through a lot in the last couple of
weeks like multiple different homes
returned adopted trainer back to my dad
who I haven't seen in two years like
it's confusing yeah so the one thing a
dog has is his name right his mommy
hasn't seen in months right
it's a period of transition for Graham
hippie and why are we making it worse
for Graham hippie
I don't know I would love to see some
research on maybe a tabula rasa being
good for Graham hippie perhaps now one
thing about me like I am gonna forget
that James Kennedy is George Michael's
God kid godson I'm gonna forget it for
sure but I'm oh but I'm gonna know that
he has ties to
fancy English people
yeah I just think it's like convenient
like George Michael's not here to rebuke
that you know well George Michael is his
Godfather even if like he you know
doesn't want to get drinks with James
like that that's facts
according to hell
no like it's definitely his Godfather
like according to James's Mom and Dad
yeah I'm sure there's photos and things
yeah you're right it's just like it's so
inconceivable to me I'm just like I have
a hard time believing and not because
it's not true just because it's a very
you know unbelievable thing yeah but it
reminds me a lot of dirty people yeah of
course it does and the other George
what's his name Boy George Boy George
because also we met James and Dory kind
of at the same time they both have like
ties to fancy English people no but at
least like Boy George is like on the
show Boy George vouches for dorit and PK
he would go to bat for them no and I
forget who I was just with somebody who
works
um
for someone they work on George like a
bunch of Tours and George Michael's tour
and I was like have you ever met PK he's
like yeah he's at every show like he
actually is Boy George's manager you
know yeah
there's no denying that
yeah
so
we'll see what happens Graham hippie was
on the trip in Tahoe so we'll definitely
learn more about this story when we
watch VPR yeah it's giving Lucy Lucy
apple juice and everybody's like
collectively rolling their eyes because
that was such a treacherous time
personally I loved the apple apple Juicy
Lucy goosey era because that was when
like it was kind of the um
the Reckoning of Lisa Vanderpump yeah
I liked that time
yeah I don't roll my eyes at it like
some people do no no me neither
especially not now like with so much
hindsight like it was very pivotal to
the whole franchise right it was who no
who would have thought that would have
been the beginning of the end for Lisa
Vanderpump yeah
we had all had so much fun that day
we had no idea how terrible things would
soon become
are you ready for our next story yeah
happy birthday is in order for Selena
Gomez she is celebrated she celebrated
her 31st birthday this weekend with
Paris Hilton Christina Aguilera a Barbie
screening
a bunch of other celebs so she marked
her 31st birthday with a huge party with
friends and shared a series of behind
the scenes images from the celebrations
on Instagram on Sunday she just wrote a
simple caption 31 and she showed off her
gorgeous outfit I believe her dress was
Valentino something like that she looks
really beautiful looked like a fun party
lots of stars some of her best friends
were missing like Taylor Who's obviously
busy understandable Nicola is in San
Tropez with her family but posted you
know something very sweet for Selena's
birthday and it looked like a fun night
was had by all
yeah I feel like Selena like Loki throws
like a great birthday every year and
even though she seems um
like she's not like a thirsty celebrity
she's always like out and about with
other celebs she really has so many
celebrity friends like high profile
friends so her birthdays are always like
a fabulous
event yeah I don't recall her other
birthdays but I remember last year
I'm sure she did something big for her
30th 30th right this was like a little
bit more low-key a Barbie screening is
really cute yeah very cute and it was
cool to see who she is friends with and
unexpected
by the way Barbie's now been out I know
well that's our fifth and final Story
the numbers are in they are yeah okay
well let's keep talking about Selena
before we dive into that but I am really
curious because I haven't seen the
numbers yet yeah no numbers are in you
know and reviews are in two from both
the critics and the lay people and we
will talk about it but yeah Barbie
screening is very cool
oh did what are your thoughts on like
you know because it was Barbie opening
weekend people getting like really
dressed up to go see Barbie there was
like a lot of discourse about it on the
internet
um people were like making fun of other
people I thought it was cute I will
always be into that I will always be
into like people having like finding a
reason to like dress nicer than they
would have you know back in the day when
people went to see a movie it was like a
a very exciting Affair and now people
dress like complete slobs because just
that's like the the culture and that's
also the way that the
the movies just are now and I I do I do
it too like I'm not gonna yeah it's the
way like in there for a while it should
be yeah yeah like same with airplanes
you know it's like why the would I
wear a skirt
jeans with a button terrible but it's
also because like now we eat so much at
the movies
so true you know and we have like these
huge sodas
maybe I'll go see a movie tonight
because Ben's gone
what should I say
you should see Bart I feel like for the
podcast I should see Barbie but like I
low-key ever since I read the rose code
like my whole personality's changed I
kind of want to see Oppenheimer actually
Josh Peck is in it I know I want to see
Oppenheimer too
I'll see you honestly at whatever
theater near me has better times and is
playing you know
theaters like in New York are like so
um like in trouble they're not like
playing a million movies at the same
time it's not like it used to be like
two two thirty three like it's literally
three shows maybe two movies
yeah so when something is popular it's
actually hard to get a ticket yeah my
theater like the upstairs is closed all
the like all the concessions and the
theaters that were upstairs no they
can't keep the lights on so it's only
the ones downstairs yeah well you know
what let's get into our fifth and final
story Barb and Heimer weekend and I want
to let you know that today's episode is
brought to you by Dreamland babyco which
is a brand that I am loving as a mama
and I can't wait to tell you guys all
about it and also let you know that if
you go to dreamlandbabyco.com and enter
our code toast at checkout you will
receive 20 off-site wide plus free
shipping this offer is for new and
existing customers so definitely take
advantage of that so if you don't know
Dreamland baby Co is responsible for the
Dreamland baby swaddle which is an
amazing baby swaddle it will help your
baby feel more relaxed sleep deeper
swaddling is so important for babies who
want to keep their arms in it depends on
their age but there are all these
different stages of swaddling and I love
the Dreamland baby Co one because you
can use that swaddle all three different
ways with both arms in one arm out both
arms out Harry used to sleep with one
arm out which is just really cute it has
a two-way zipper for fuss-free diaper
changes in the middle of the night you
don't want to have to take the whole
thing off so you can just zip from the
bottom and it has evenly distributed
weight with their cover com technology
so think about the way you feel when you
sleep with a weighted blanket how it you
know decreases anxiety and stress like
it does that before your little baby
which is so wonderful it's also 100 soft
uses natural cotton it's a wonderful
wonderful product for babies
we've loved ours the Dreamland baby
swaddle it will really help if you are
on a sleep Journey struggle so again
that's dreamlandbabyco.com enter code
toast at checkout to receive 20 off site
wide plus free shipping this offer is
for new and existing customers enjoy
today's episode is also brought to you
by Mattress Firm it can be intimidating
knowing what type of mattress you need
to get a quality night sleep mattress
firms Sleep Experts get over 200 hours
of training so they can pair you with
the right mattress and accessories to
get a quality night's sleep did you know
that the Comfort level of a mattress can
help alleviate pain tossing and turning
even isolate motion if you sleep with a
significant other that's the thing me
and Ben have like such different sleep
needs so when we were looking for a
mattress our mattress is for Mattress
Firm
um it was very difficult and we went
into the store and they were so helpful
so you can chat with a sleep chat with
the Sleep Experts in store or online to
find your sleep solution they'll ask you
questions to understand what keeps you
up at night they'll help match you with
a high quality mattress they carry tons
of top brands like Tempur-Pedic which is
our brand of mattress they have Stearns
and Foster Serta nectar Beautyrest
sleepies and if you're looking for one
of those convenient mattresses in a box
Mattress Firm can also help with that
because the last thing you want to worry
about is delivery Mattress Firm offers
free and fast delivery I can attest it
was so seamless so easy and the guys
were so nice mattress firm helps you uh
with more than just mattresses too they
also have mattress accessories like
mattress protectors adjustable bases to
bring your comfort level to 100. one
thing that's important to Mattress Firm
is that they have great deals even
outside of their sales events like right
now you can save on the right mattress
by shopping in store or online at
mattressfirm.com of course they have
huge sales throughout the year but even
when it's not those sales time they have
great deals so right now you can save on
the right mattress by shopping in store
or or online at mattress firm.com that's
m-a-t-t-r-e-s-s firm f-i-r-m.com
thank you Claudia between those two you
should have a great night's sleep it's
so true sleep is incredibly important to
us here at the toast and our sponsors
just merely reflect that
Fifth and final story box office news
Barbie opens to a record-setting 155
million dollar weekend while Oppenheimer
shatters expectations with an 80 million
dollar debut so barberheimer fueled the
fourth biggest box office weekend in
history
over the weekend movie govers turned out
in force for Barbie which smashed
expectations with 155 million to land
the biggest debut of the year but also
Oppenheimer came out good with 80
million in its opening weekend I think
the budget for that was probably not as
right the budget for Barbie was I think
150 so to like get your budget back and
then a little bit more in opening
weekend is like a really I think major
accomplishment 150 including the
marketing budget
I don't know because you know everyone's
talking about this 100 million dollar
marketing budget
oh so was it like 250
perhaps you know what let's look how
much did Barbie
cost to make
yeah 145 million not including marketing
which we've got ways to go which we know
was a hundred
they've got ways they have ways to go
but also if you include Global sales I
think it did uh 182 million globally
which made the whole weekend 337 million
dollars
oh okay so that's misleading yeah unless
like it was only 100 million dollar
Marketing in the US and if you go Global
then the you know the bill goes up
anyways
hundreds of thousands of ticket buyers
refuse to choose between the two
seemingly different Blockbusters with
sprawling cast and twin release dates so
they opted to attend same-day viewings
of Barbie and Oppenheimer
um people said this is an unequivocally
great weekend for movie going the movies
are complementing each other at the box
office not taking audience away from
each other the cultural craze known as
barberheimer work to fuel the biggest
Collective box office weekend of the
pandemic era duh as well as the fourth
biggest overall overall weekend in
history the other top three weekends
were Avengers end game Avengers Infinity
war and Star Wars the Force awakens yeah
I feel like these days movies that
aren't like action or DC Marvel like
don't make those lists so this is great
for you know burgeoning movie genres
um it's also just like kind of a perfect
storm like these two movies I don't know
how barberheimer like got so viral but
it's just been like a a marketing dream
yeah but it's also worth noting this is
like the combined power of two movies
versus those other movies were one movie
that's true that's still still strong
especially in this day and age and it's
also the biggest opening for a female
director ever Greta Greta
do not tune
not tune I don't know how she feels
about Barbie I'm sure she has a problem
yeah I also don't know if I feel like
people are saying this but I don't know
if it's necessarily true like I don't
really feel like the strike impacted the
ability for people to promote the film
it's like the strike happened at the
perfect time like everyone was just
about to be done promoting well the part
of the strike where people are no longer
allowed to promote happened like the
perfect time but the strike right that's
going on for weeks and Barbie has been
being promoted for weeks and then I'm
also seeing on my Instagram so much
Barbie promo like from people
influencers both like and there's so
many brands that are doing doing collabs
I'm pretty sure the number was a hundred
brands that that would be worked with
but I get I'm getting all these emails
in my inbox from brands that I like you
know shop at and they all have like a
Barbie line I'm like saying you guys
hand selected by Mattel to partner with
the movie or can anybody now just like
put the Barbie trademark on stuff oh
that's a good question I wonder how it
worked for collabs but like literally
everything I got bum suit Barbie
Barefoot dreams Barbie Pinkberry Barbie
I got um uh cupcakes everything is
Barbie and then also I'm like so are
those Brands and you know social media
accounts not crossing the picket line by
promoting the movie I'm seeing so much
that's interesting promo also like
influencers who are dressed up as Barbie
and I'm also like some of it seems
sponsored some of it doesn't it just
seems like a you know A Gifted or a
party or something but I'm like are they
crossing the pick a line right I think
it's we Jack and I have been sending
each other things back and forth because
I think um it's interesting and I'm
admittedly don't fully understand like
what's considered crossing the picket
line but I I feel like even you can't
really not talk about Barbie like it's
so in the culture and it's talking about
it considered promoting it I don't know
right and also what's the point of not
promoting the movie is it so that people
don't see it because wouldn't that
hinder hurt the the industry even more
like I was thinking that too like if you
want to support the strike should you
not see the movie right that's what I'm
wondering I don't know if that's not the
case if that doesn't support the strike
by not seeing the movie then why does
promoting the movie not support the
strike
no I don't know
I'm not sure
um
no I don't know but I did see this video
of um you know because people who are in
Sag can't and won't go to the premieres
of course Studios have just like widened
the net of who who can go and I think it
was the one in Milan where it was like
exclusively like content creators and
everyone just like looked crazy
um it was really funny I don't know I
don't know I right and like are those
content creators are they the ones that
we were talking about last week who it's
like influencers you're gonna get
opportunities that you never would have
gotten but don't take that because
you're not standing with the strikers
like is that what that what this is so I
had gotten a message from a toaster
who's like in Sag and a working actor
and she like explained so much of the
strike to me
um but per the influencers being like
scabs conversation she said yes if
Universal Netflix Amazon Etc pay an
influencer to promote a film or a show
during the strike and they do it they
might not be eligible to join sag later
on so yes it's like the money could be
great but you're closing off future
opportunities and closing future doors
of opportunities for what might only be
a couple months of a strike
um okay but so I think it's the exchange
of money okay that's you crossing the
picket line got it good to know that but
if they're
joining if they're working with Studios
on behalf of like promoting that doesn't
necessarily mean that those influencers
like want to be actors one day no no but
but you know influencer the job of being
an influencer brings you so many
different opportunities that like you
know down the line you actually might
get booked on a role that requires you
to be in Sag and if you did something
years ago you're closing off that
opportunity got it and but it doesn't
close off the opportunity for in the
future for the that studio to book you
again for promotion
no because you don't need to be in Sag
to to be like paid to film a movie but I
don't know if you just like go to see
Barbie and you're not being paid but you
like post about it on Instagram is that
being scab
and not according to what this person
told you yeah I think it's the exchange
of money
got it
okay so it's all very interesting and I
don't actually think that the strike
hindered uh people going to see the
movie and I'm not sure if you know if
you want to support the strike if you
should see the movie or not I feel like
you still should
I don't know yeah it doesn't it seems
like it would be good to support the
industry right the movie does well but
and a female director but do the studios
suffer if the movie does Port like maybe
the people who worked on movies get paid
the same regardless and now if you want
to do this to feel the pain you don't go
see the movie yeah that's perhaps
if you want to stem at the strike maybe
you don't go see the movie
but I haven't seen that anywhere but it
just seems like a logical conclusion
right you don't want people to promote
it oh and you know what else I'd listen
to I actually um on the car ride to we
listened to a Tim Dylan episode oh my
God it was so funny and he's in Sag but
he's also like a comedian and he was
being really funny about it and but his
overall point which I found so
interesting was like this strike will
come to an end like everyone will of
course you know agree on something but
and one of the major points in the
strike is AI and he was like
the studio will budge on a lot of things
they will not budge on AI like they will
give Fran and the writers what they want
on a lot of things they'll all meet in
the middle but AI is not something that
they will budge on because it's he said
it's unrealistic for Hollywood to not
start automating when literally every
industry has done it in history and like
Hollywood is not this like deeply
ethical moral business it's a business
known to exploit people and you know has
a very dark history so to expect like
the utmost morality from Hollywood is
just unrealistic so writers in terms of
like residuals and royalties a lot of
what they're fighting for is like you
know shows are going so viral on Netflix
or whatever and a writer or even a star
of it is making five cents like he said
the royalties he thinks like all a lot
of what they're fighting for will change
but the AI he doesn't think Hollywood
will budge on yeah and I it makes sense
that the business model has to change
from like the days of studios and and
networks to the days of streaming like
just like how the music industry had to
change from the days of you know selling
CDs yes and all that stuff to now
streaming but I feel like they kind of
figured it out I mean it's still they
have it's not great it's it's better
like it's conversations being had but I
don't think there's unions in music
so there was never like a big strike and
a big conversation being had about it it
was just you know powerful people like
Taylor Swift speaking out causing change
got it very interesting and have you
seen this Andrew Schultz tweet that's
like gone viral
yes theory about the strike
yes yes that basically if
in order to pay residuals to all these
shows on the streamers the streamers
would have to say how many people are
watching the shows but they don't
release their numbers they do release
minute stream for some of their biggest
shows but what the is minute
streamed how many people watch a show
yeah the analytics that that like
Netflix and these big streamers put out
are like really vague and I think in
Tech it's like very common for people to
like inflate their numbers and then
their valuation gets inflated and their
stock goes up so if they had to be
totally transparent about their
analytics what Andrew Schultz said is
like it would be bad for business yeah
no he said that their numbers are not
what the stock price reflects right now
so their stock price would go down and
actually ultimate this is his theory and
that ultimately it would hurt everyone
because if the Netflix stock price goes
down they will have less money to spend
they will make less shows and there will
be less working actors working crew
working everything and they'll only keep
making those one percent of shows that
do amazing but there is so much content
on all these streamers and most of them
don't have huge audiences yeah I
actually remember so weird you know like
just one thing like your teacher taught
you like actually sticks video I took
like a media class and it was all it was
more about cable but it was like one in
every 10 shows sorry nine in every 10
shows on air lose millions of dollars
but that one show that does well makes
enough money to keep all 10 on that's
what Mr Wonderful says about his
Investments
um
that 10 of Investments like pay for the
other 90 that fail and then I forget who
else told me this but I think I said
this on the show already about
mid-september did I say that Friday yeah
you did that people will be the strike
the strike will be over by mid-september
it will be more exactly it will be more
pertinent to end it than it is right now
we're going into August which is the
quietest Monday year yep
oh very interesting did you think the
Oppenheimer was going to do better than
Barbie I don't know why I did even
though like Barbie's everywhere I just
felt like Oppenheimer would do better I
don't know why I didn't really know
anything about Oppenheimer like I still
don't really know much about Christopher
Nolan but the the people in that article
were saying like they expected
Oppenheimer to do 50 million because
it's like it's like grittier subject
matter you know it's not as
light-hearted but it seemed like there
was this whole huge cult following to
the effect that it was Barb and Heimer
like if it was not as big as Barbie like
it would have been Barbie's weekend yeah
but I guess it depends how we're looking
at success because like yes Barbie made
more but Barbie also most definitely
spent more right so like whose profit is
bigger probably Oppenheimer
I don't know me neither
well I'm gonna see it maybe I'll see
Barbie tonight let me see if anybody
wants to go with him I'm sure Zach would
go with you oh my God yeah Zach loves
the movies Zach loves the movies
hmm okay have fun great
so those were the past five
and people are saying it's good people
are some people are loving it some
people are liking it I've seen a couple
hates but I think that it's actually
pretty good Barbie yeah no I'll be I'll
be completely honest when I see it I
feel no I'm not difficult to impress as
long as movies like under two hours if
it's over if it's over two hours I will
hate it and I'll give you a bunch of
reasons but just know it's because it
was over two hours yeah yeah let me look
it up Barbie runtime
but it also includes like credits yeah
oh hour 54. gorgeous
no but then with credits it's probably
hour 30 like if you take out the end
probably like an hour 45.
those credits run forever
they do all right I'm gonna see if I can
get tickets
yeah good luck
well that's our show mm-hmm
hope everyone ready has an amazing
Monday
I hope so too I too hope that for you
you do yeah I do all right well actually
I'm going to come over soon I want to
see you and Harry so I'll see you in a
bit that's so sweet thank you guys and
we need to talk about your week I need
to know what's going on with my turkey
yeah we need to kind of like schedule
things
totally thank you guys so much for
listening to The Chosen Linda Morning
Show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know everybody
Friday on YouTube so you're watching us
on YouTube please don't forget to
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available to podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so on Spotify
iTunes Stitcher if it's still around
public radio I already castbox all the
places I've listened to podcast find us
the toasty if I serve you about a
beautiful stunning and wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have an amazing day
and we'll see you tomorrow bye love ya
bye